uh let's talk about mcgregor poirier
um you all got to see it we saw the
fight where we were watching it at your
wedding no disrespect
all good uh the wedding had technically
finished by the time the fight came on
uh it was cool you guys did that
actually oh yeah it was very i actually
thought about that
thank you very much we really appreciate
that um
okay so let's talk about this because
this is really interesting what's going
on with conor mcgregor
i post fight i am seeing him
behave with the desperation that i've
never seen
yeah it's sad it is really interesting
he's super concerned with narrative
yeah there's an insecurity that i
haven't seen in him before
uh for all of you guys you know watching
listening right now obviously you know
what happened he snapped his tibia right
so he didn't like
he basically broke his leg clean tibia
amphibia i guess both bones that are in
your
your right above your ankle so he
snapped those clean
uh and and then yeah the you know the
fight got stopped
you know doctor stoppage but it was
really important to him during the fight
hey this isn't a tko loss dustin didn't
beat me it's a doctor stoppage
it feels as if he knows his prime is
slipping away
his time as the elite mma fighter that
we knew him at is a slipping away
and he is trying to hold on to it with
[ __ ] everything dude
um it's really interesting what's going
on man what do you think
do you think it's not just his pr i
think his prime is slipped away it's
done after this to me
as a very very casual fan do you think
he's like
oh my legacy is tarnished at this point
i think
his deal with proper 12 yeah
had stipulations oh boy
that he might not be able to meet oh boy
i have no proof to back this up but
if you get 100 million or whatever the
[ __ ] it is for proper 12 but it's put in
there
you got to fight this many more times
and you either have to win the ufc
championship or
fight manny pacquiao or
because he's like we're coming back
we're fighting again i still want to do
it why do you want to do it
you got fake teeth i felt that you got
[ __ ] botox like you fix your like
what are you doing here what purpose do
you have as soon as you sent the thing
that he had botox and i looked at his
face i was like he gonna lose
it's done yeah botox
right now nothing wrong absolutely we
all gonna be there but but
but you know what i mean like he's
obviously caring about the way he looks
he's being uh
and breaking your leg [ __ ] sucks dude
have you broken your leg before
nah like i broke my arm but like the
idea of like breaking your [ __ ] leg
like
not being able to walk six weeks into
the crotch for what dude like you know
what i mean like he knows
like he doesn't want this you got a
hundred million dollars you have your
family you have all these different
things
he's still cursing him out saying his
wife is in his dms as he's leaving like
you got absolutely bullied like we'll
talk about the beginning of the fight
where
connor was out boxing him easily but
then dustin landed two big shots on
connor
yeah it caused conor to kind of grab him
and then once they were grabbed
i mean dustin's just a far superior
wrestler jujitsu
ground and pound and then dustin just
bullied him on the ground i mean conor
was just there doing absolutely nothing
right yeah on the feet connor was out
boxing him yeah and he looked really
good he was laying some big kicks
do you think he broke his leg on the
check i don't think
people are saying he like doesn't check
it with his elbow but then i saw another
angle it doesn't look like he hit him
when i was speaking to a buddy of mine
who works in the nba and he said that
the trainer and his team said those
breaks often happen because of over
training so the bone is already depleted
due to the over training and i know that
conor likes to ride the bike but every
time i see him doing cardio he's on a
bike
and that always makes me curious because
biking is not a great form of cardio
uh in terms of time efficiency you want
to get your cardio up on a bike you're
biking for hours dude okay
whereas if you want to run for an hour
yeah
i mean you're doing miles right you're
running for an hour
but bike you really got to be on that
[ __ ] thing for a while in order for
it to really tap into your cardio right
unless you're maybe going uphill or
something it's just not an efficient
source
but i wonder if his legs were hurt
that's running so no it's because you
trained too hard not even because you
got beat
because you just like wanted it too
badly that said yeah
yeah ronda rousey said that when conor
was on the ground after the fight and
almost marketing his next battle like
he'll be back like no other fighter
would ever think about like promoting
why is he so desperate to do it
there has to be something like he's
immediately going yes and then he's also
saying oh we're definitely gonna have a
fight with nate diaz we're gonna have a
trilogy fight with that like
what is going on yeah that you are
holding on to your place in this sport
even after you have a hundred million in
the bank is he maniacal
is that is it just a sociopathic like
urge to
beat people up i hope it's great i don't
think so but i
hope it's that what do you think i like
i had this theory
before i think it's the proper 12. i
know you he sold all his stake in it but
i still think
like you said there's some type of
clause where he needs to win he needs to
keep winning
you know how like sometimes you could
sell a company like i think dana white
has sold his portion of
the ufc yeah but i think as part of that
deal and selling your company you have
to stay on for a certain term and manage
suggest
these shares so in other words your
shares vest
over four years or something and this is
the the people who
sell or bought the company's way of
maintaining the skill level
yeah not the skill level but the
operation guy knows how i think he got
it to this point i wanted to stay there
get it to a bigger point and then he's
free and he gets his money yeah i wonder
if those things are built into his con
there has to be something dude
why is he so [ __ ] tired i thought it
was he's sorry to interrupt but he's on
his story i never see him on his story
he's on his story in his hospital bed
right after the break
hey surgery went amazing we're back
that's an illegitimate win from dustin
he's not he's really trying to create
narrative
he's posting stuff in his story about
like the shots and how they didn't land
from dustin there was no ground in pound
yeah
something's up two things one i might
have messed up the nate diaz thing i
reread the article even though it's
posted like 12
hours ago or whatever on tmz it might
have been before the fight they were
saying there will be a trilogy fight
which would which would make sense with
your proper 12 thing also right i though
think it
is a lot of it is uh he's going to lose
relevance
once he isn't fighting anymore how does
he stay relevant
and the thing about a guy that's that
good at getting attention
is that's a pretty intoxicating feeling
you are that good at getting attention
you're going to get a lot of attention
once you get it
you don't know what to do when it goes
away that's true he loves attention and
he's good at getting it
and it's really addictive so once you
are
not good at the thing that got to the
attention in the first place
that probably [ __ ] with you your theory
makes a ton of sense too
my initial read was nah i think he
is losing relevance and it's pathetic to
watch him grabbing for yeah maybe maybe
i think that's completely plausible two
questions can you explain that the
judge's scorecard for round one came in
at like ten nine
ten eight ten eight agreed tonight is
for dustin
yeah yeah so dustin was so dominant in
the round that they took
two points away yeah and i don't think
that that's unreasonable i think he was
very dominant now i i wouldn't have
given it 10 8
because i thought connor dominated on
the feet
like while they were standing conor was
dominant
i mean dustin landed the shot that kind
of like staggered
conor but i mean conor was kicking his
legs off i mean
he was really out boxing and out kicking
him
but uh once he had him on the ground
connor is just useless on the ground
like
yeah okay it's in second yeah
he's gonna fight dustin for sure again
dustin just destroys him do you think
this opens it up for a uh
potential connor jake paul fight
after does that is that what this leads
to in the ufc world or this might have
also been before the fight but i read in
articles
again from tmz saying uh the manager
saying there's no way he fights jake
paul now again that might have been
before the fight
and if you lose this badly and get not
this badly but if you get kind of
embarrassed like that like you're like
just broke mid-fight
and you're grabbing for anything and
relevance and all that it could jay
paul's
that's an easy source it would be so
[ __ ]
entertaining it would be entertaining
it's a real bummer because
i wanted connor to win not necessarily
because i like him so much
personally i just everything is better
when conor's winning
yeah everything is better in sports
entertainment
yeah everything is better like when you
have a charismatic
fighter yes that is on top of the world
yes
ask him any question what do we do about
israel palestine
just let him go like let it i want conor
at peak confidence
yeah in every setting and then doing
interviews going on different podcasts
like
talking about other fights like when
conor
connor can't talk about the next kumar
usman fight yeah because he just got his
[ __ ] ankle broken
so he's gotta sit down and shut the [ __ ]
up even if he does talk it's like
you go sit down shut the [ __ ] up shut
the [ __ ] up if he knocked pourier out in
brutal fashion
right yeah he's talking so much [ __ ]
about everybody on the roster you gotta
listen
guys knock somebody out he got the right
to talk mm-hmm you get to talk if you
beat somebody's ass knock somebody out
you get to run your mouth
what are we gonna say that dustin's one
of the best ufc fighters son we have to
i mean like
all credit to dustin he is a [ __ ]
bully and frankly he's got conor's left
hand timed
really like yeah he caught him a couple
times again like he just
conor takes a it's he's not slow in
throwing it
but it comes from far back and you don't
have to worry about his right hand
at all like he doesn't have a strong jab
or a good hook so you just got to worry
about one hand and
dustin's a really good boxer like really
good
and he timed out that [ __ ] left hand
of connors
and oh yeah yeah man it's a it's a
bummer though
yeah it's a [ __ ] box but like his
last loss in the last five years was
khabib
yeah dominating wins over other people
man
yeah so to me i'm like i mean you should
be in the
be in the combo yeah i mean yeah i mean
i think once he gets the belt
he'll fight charles oliveira and then if
he beats charles like
which is not easy but if he beats him i
think that he's
he's definitely in the combat you know
what i was what you said something about
connor you know it reminded me
of when he hit his peak this was his
influence i don't remember the last
white athlete that influenced that black
athletes were doing their [ __ ]
like i remember i think dez bryant
caught a touchdown pass and then on the
sidelines
everybody was doing that [ __ ] like he's
a [ __ ] irish guy
like the whitest white guy and he's
influencing black culture
i don't remember the last time that
happened especially not in sports
that's the power of a great fight is the
greatest fight promoter i've ever seen
yeah i mean better than i have i wasn't
around for ali so i don't know what
those times were like and i'm sure they
were unbelievable
but he's better than floyd that way
better than floyd it was that was
amazing and floyd is amazing and when
they fought conor was the one carrying
very dead dude what he did he didn't
even promote this fight until like three
days before
and once he started everything was a
quote yeah
every [ __ ] thing he said say
something
i was completely in wedding the best one
is uh i break people's faces and bounce
yeah yeah yeah so bad dude it was
unbelievable he goes i don't
yeah he goes i know something somebody
asked him what he does he is i don't do
that
i break people i'm not a celebrity i
don't care about fame
yeah because i'm not a celebrity i don't
care about celebrity i
break people's faces and bounce like
oh my god give me carried on a stretcher
he's a corpse he's a corpse he'll kill
him
i'm gonna end his life that man will pay
with his
life yeah dude oh my god it's
unbelievable like just making [ __ ] up
i've only got one loss in the ring i
only count losses
from knockouts whoever shoots first a
[ __ ] he's a [ __ ]
you know taps they don't count he
immediately puts dustin and guillotine
the second he gets
that's where i'm like why doesn't every
fighter just watch that and go like is
that
they just don't got it bro yeah you got
to have that got it you got
like everybody has just talking wild
[ __ ]
it wouldn't be fun large of charisma is
something you have or you don't
yeah and then there's things you can do
to it's like athleticism it's like any
trait
charisma is something a lot of people
are just born with and a lot of people
are just not
right charisma is a suit man you know
some people just look amazing in a suit
and other people look like they're going
to court
right you know like connor looks great
in the suit bro yeah
he really does everything fits yeah and
and that guy can sell a fight and
you know dana and the ufc they're upset
not because they don't want to see
dustin when i'm sure they like dustin i
sure
think he's really skilled it's just so
much easier to sell
connor yeah like connor versus charles
oliveira
they literally just go okay kyle will do
all the work should we make
advertisements or no no
no billboards
[Applause]